i was having dinner with aaron rodgers
and and rappers love aaron ross oh wow
okay okay okay that's you that's you
this is my denzel no okay all right i
wasn't even trying to do it because you
know now since you now since you want to
get into it okay yeah you want to you
want to talk to me you want to talk to
me like that so he was talking
to new york
never noticed he had new york yeah yeah
he's from mount vernon yeah oh man yeah
yeah yeah you ever get to yeah
yeah oh you know that place you know on
uh huh you just put this wagon there
okay yeah yeah yeah the duck swords give
me the duck sauce
yeah yeah yeah the duck sauce the duck
sauce on there yeah
dude like
it's not just the voices you fought you
mine it and you find yeah yeah the ducks
i couldn't do it if you gave me 45
minutes you can do it you can do it you
know you can do it that's what he would
say that's right you can't tell yourself
that you can't do it pete you can do
anything you put your [__] mind
through your boys and girls club where's
my girl's clothes and girls club get up
in there boys get up in there even
though there's a lot of people who steal
huh
yeah i got stolen from that's where the
bullying started huh
that's real [__] what did denzel say to
will smith
[Laughter]
it's amazing
denzel go up to will after the slap yeah
yeah yeah so so i approached will
afterwards and i um
and i talked to him i said listen
i said
when you're at your high that's when the
devil aims at you that's right that's
right
um
so you make sure you got to make sure
you you do well too what is what's that
yeah you know it's like you know it's
like insane because
you know like
i never thought that i never thought i
would like react like that
you know when
you know because it happened so
spontaneously but
you know like
like pete you gotta understand that you
know um yeah um
i've been like pushed like constantly
like over the years and like the thing
with chris was it was like you know he
said some things in 2016 and like you
know i really didn't like it and like
you know that was and
i had nothing to do
nothing to do with jada nothing at all
it was it was just totally me oh and
like i take full accountability and i
will also like to say again you know
that to chris's mother you know like i'm
sorry for like you know smacking your
son
and you know making him look like a
[__]
on national television his publicist
yeah
i mean i mean like making him look soft
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no no no no no no no
i mean i mean i mean you know
attacking him
yeah
did y'all get that yeah check it out yes
totally awesome
that is so good that's good
mother
mother is will smith again
yeah yeah my mother
what is going on it's just like you know
it's like the you know taking that
and like it's the movement
of everything you know just like the
mouth
you know the the nose the ears like if
he wants to get back into social media
he needs to use me as psas and like you
know
deep fake or have me talk for him
because everything is better in
chocolate yeah
yeah
he's like caramel do a little chris rock
cause i'm just gonna
i can't hear missing the best part
you just did will smith for five minutes
listen listen man like you know i got
smacked so what like
i'll talk about it it'll be funny but
whatever duh like
what can you do i got smacked by the
softest [__] in hollywood
i got smacked by
the suge knight of kindergarten okay
like
[Laughter]
you turned me into black church like i'm
like like def jam like i have to like
get up
you're so funny you have to like make it
physical like you have to like get up
and move around and stuff it's it's just
too much that's it
that's it
oh my god that was great i i felt bad
morning radioing you but that like i i
just knew you could do it it was so good
not but the good thing was that you were
talking about was um we were talking
about getting bullied that's what we
were talking about
yeah yeah the duck sauce but the duck
sauce up there in the duck stores that's
what it is right only denzel could make
sweet orange chinese sauce sound
[Laughter]
pete holmes my man that's where he is
huh
okay
like you know what i got i got to say
something about you you know because uh
it was uh
you know you said this joke and i
thought it was really funny you said um
you reference yourself like val kilmer
and you said um
it was just so it was so it was so funny
to me because that the first time i
looked at you i was like yo val looks
good he's you know he's
you know you know he's eating less gucci
and he looks good
you know that's what happened right huh
that's right he can't talk because he
kept eating the box okay all right is
that how he got it well i don't know but
you know that's how michael comes up
[Laughter]
oh yeah that's where he got it from huh
i guess it was good you know you keep
returning
hey sometimes you you know what's bad
no no no no no no then
um
[Music]